I'm Rakesh Mohan I'm senior fellow the
Jackson is due to a global affairs and
also professor international economics
in the School of Management I have the
privilege of introducing ambassador or
excellency nirupama rao we delighted
that you are visiting Yale I'm
particularly delighted because I
graduated from here and now I'm teaching
here so very nice to see you here for
just to give a few words of introduction
mrs. Rao is of course now the ambassador
of India to United States she retired as
foreign secretary of India where she was
for insect leave 2009-2011 which is the
highest position in the Indian Foreign
Service what is quite amazing about a
career in foreign services that she
served in all parts the world except
perhaps Africa so that she's been
ambassador to China she's been
ambassador to Sri Lanka she's been
ambassador to Peru and Bolivia and also
the deputy chief of mission to Moscow
among the other thing is that she was
also the chief spokesperson for the
minister of External Affairs 2001 2002
and I do remember during the somewhat
unfortunate meeting between prime
minister watch pie and President
Musharraf that you had to then bear the
burden of explaining or not explaining
what happened in Agra and remember very
well those of us were in Delhi watching
you and wondering what you're going to
say when that happened she's a real true
representative India having grown up in
all parts of the country bangalore pinay
lucknow coonoor so all part of the
country she husband is also his most
recent retired as chief secretary of
Karnataka also a distinguished civil
servant and was quite amazing in having
served all over the world husband being
busy fellow also in the Union admissible
service I don't know how you raised two
in doing all that there is one error
that she is made in a life which is that
she went to Harvard CIA that is Howard
center first national affairs and I
guess that's because Jackson is she
didn't exist then so there's still a
chance for you to make up for your error
in the past ambassador up Thank You
professor Rakesh mohand dr. Joe Joseph
dear friends students and delighted to
be here this evening at Yale University
one of the finest seats of learning and
the imparting of knowledge it's really
an honor for me to address all of you
this evening on the subject of india-us
relations Yale has had a historical
connection with India that goes back
more than three centuries and we all
know the story of Elihu Yale and his
days in Madras now called Chennai in
fact Yale has been a pioneer among us
universities when it comes to the study
of India it's languages its literature
its religions its history its politics
economics and society I understand that
Yale was the first u.s. University to
begin the teaching of Sanskrit many
eminent Indians and Indian Americans
have passed through its portals Yale is
not only continuing its engagement with
India today but has strengthened it and
broadened it through the Yale India
initiative that was launched in 2008 I'm
aware of the leadership programs that
you have and the Indian parliamentarians
who have been coming to Yale in that
context and also the recently initiated
program that involves Vice Chancellors
many of them here
from leading indian universities whom
you have brought to Yale this is an
excellent initiative and I hope it
gathers strength and momentum in the
years to come and I know there are about
if I'm if I'm not mistaken 157 Indian
students in Yale today that is a
significant number I believe their
second only to the Chinese students here
and i hope the tribe of indian students
increases as the years go by especially
since you have given india such as
special and unique focus in the programs
of your university so let me say that
Yale is making a singular contribution
to fostering greater understanding
between the Indian and American people's
people-to-people connections are in fact
the warp and the weft of the rich fabric
of the india-us relationship indeed the
key element of our partnership has been
people centric and in this we seek to
respond to popular aspirations that go
beyond the calculations of political
expediency Yale is therefore I believe
doing yeomen service in promoting and
strengthening relations between our two
countries and in this context I would
like to thank dr. richard levin I know
he is traveling president of the Yale
University for his leadership and
commitment for enhancing Yale's
connections with India as both India and
the u.s. work towards becoming truly
knowledge societies we believe there are
immense opportunities to forge new links
in the areas of education research and
innovation as also technology and skill
development therefore the deepening of
our cooperation in the field of
education has been identified by both
governments as a key priority as we
chart the course ahead for our strategic
partnership india-us cooperation in the
field of edgy
creation is therefore poised for major
expansion today we in India see
education as critical for achieving our
goals to have inclusive growth and to
realize the potential to take the Indian
economy on an even higher growth
trajectory our government has announced
new initiatives major initiatives for
massive expansion and upgradation of the
education infrastructure both in the
primary education sector as also higher
education in a little over a week from
now the first India us higher education
summit will be held in washington DC
co-chaired by our minister of human
resource development and the United
States Secretary of State the summit
will bring together not just government
officials but also academics and
entrepreneurs who are engaged in this
area and will provide a platform to
develop blueprints for furthering our
horizons in this area this is just one
of the facets of our multifaceted
partnership with the United States today
ours is a partnership that seeks to meet
the common aspirations that both our
countries have for mutual prosperity and
for peace and security President Obama's
landmark visit to India last November
has indeed helped in elevating this
relationship to a new level the
expanding cooperation between India and
the United States is strongly rooted in
our shared values of democracy
individual freedoms and rule of law in
excellent people-to-people contacts and
business linkages and in our increasing
ability to work together in a variety of
fields from fighting the Menace of
terrorism to ensuring the stability of
the global economy in India we regard
the United States as our most important
partner in our quest for social and
economic development and we are working
to expand our
missions across the entire spectrum of
our bilateral agenda including in areas
which I believe are of importance to the
United States as well areas such as
trade and investment science and
technology clean energy health higher
education and agriculture in fact the
five key pillars of the strategic
dialogue that was initiated between the
two countries in July of 2009 when
Secretary of State Clinton visited India
for discussions with our external
affairs minister mr. sm krishna are the
following strategic cooperation energy
and climate change education and
development economic trade and
agriculture S&T that science and
technology health and education let me
take a few moments to elaborate on this
if i may say many splendored nature of
our relationship the steady growth of
the Indian economy has not only helped
improve the living standards of many of
our peoples but has also opened up new
opportunities to expand our mutually
beneficial economic and commercial ties
with the United States two-way trade in
goods continues to grow steadily
reaching about 49 billion US dollars
last year the service trade is boring
and capital flows are moving in both
directions the US businesses are
becoming strong partners in India's
growth story and Indian businesses are
creating value wealth and jobs here in
America because India US economic ties
have been knowledge technology and
people intensive they have had a
profound impact on the relationship that
goes beyond even the business sector in
order to continue on our high growth
path India will need to invest in
building a world-class infrastructure
that could cater to the demands of our
billion-plus population and ensure the
availability of clean sources of energy
to fuel such growth in both these areas
both
are working to build mutually beneficial
ties yields partnership with the Energy
Research Institute Terry for the
us-india Energy Summit in 2009 is an
example of the kind of innovative
linkages that our two countries are
tapping for partnership in the vital
area of clean energy with the u.s. we
are now engaged in seeking a broad array
of clean energy solutions in India we
have also placed the highest importance
in improving our agricultural
productivity so that it results in
better livelihoods for our rural
population we are partnering with the US
across the entire range of issues
relating to agriculture from using space
technology for better monsoon prediction
and crop productivity to improve
linkages from farm to market I
understand that Yale has developed some
excellent partnerships with China and
Chinese universities in this area it is
my hope that under your India initiative
you will be able to expand your
partnership with Indian agricultural in
universities that would benefit both
India and the u.s. health is yet another
critical area where there are insighting
opportunities for collaboration our
scientists are already working with us
institutions such as the National
Institutes of Health and the Centers for
Disease Control capitalizing on each
other's comparative advantages and
skills here again it's my hope that Yale
would take a lead in forging
partnerships with Indian institutions
for research development and deployment
of cutting-edge technologies in
pharmaceutical and biotechnology sectors
that would contribute to better health
for our peoples some exciting
developments are already taking place in
this field we've had instances where US
companies have collaborated with Indian
biotech and pharmaceutical companies to
develop cutting-edge treatment for four
serious and chronic diseases
India and the u.s. have established a
Science and Technology endowment fund to
help foster such mutually beneficial
collaborations we have also in yet
another sign of mutual confidence
overcome concerns of the past on India's
space program and have made a promising
beginning in a new area era of
cooperation I believe in Co development
of a vibrant S&T science and technology
ecosystem as a new foundation for
expanding india-us cooperation where we
harness synergies to produce global
public goods as we work to enhance our
mutual prosperity there is also an
increasing level of cooperation between
our countries to ensure peace and
security in the regional context and in
the wider global context all of us are
familiar with the challenges that our
two countries face global economic
stress profound geopolitical changes
especially in Asia as also regional
instability and the continuing threat of
terrorism especially in South Asia
whether it is terrorism or the challenge
of maintaining peace amidst fast-paced
changes in the asia-pacific the other
day I saw an Australian commentary which
call this the IND Pacific blending the
Indian and Pacific Oceans together our
interests increasingly converge our
understanding of the nature and the
source of problems that we face have
also become increasingly similar our
cooperation in the field of security has
entered new territories and explored new
frontiers our militaries once unfamiliar
with each other now hold regular
dialogue and joint exercises in the air
and on land and sea we coordinate
anti-piracy efforts and have worked
together on humanitarian missions our
defense trade was negligible a decade
ago but today we have placed orders
worth
eight billion u.s. dollars on US
companies and it is bound to grow even
more in the future as India looks to
modernize its Armed Forces the paradigm
that we visualize for defense
cooperation should incorporate a strong
component of joint production research
and co-development which are all of
strategic importance our
counterterrorism cooperation has
acquired new momentum and depth with the
homeland security dialogue and the
counterterrorism initiative even as
India continues to take steps to improve
our domestic capabilities to counter
this threat in Afghanistan we are not
only engaged in our individual
assistance efforts but are now working
together in areas such as
capacity-building agriculture and
women's empowerment both our countries
understand the imperative of ensuring
success in Afghanistan and defeating the
evil designs of those who propagate in
stability while successful transition of
security in Afghanistan in 2014 is
important that alone would not guarantee
long-term stability in the region this
would require building Afghan
institutions Afghan capacities and more
importantly the elimination of safe
havens and the infrastructure for
terrorism and violent extremism in
Afghanistan and Pakistan a goal that
both our countries share in common India
has invested significant resources in
Afghanistan's development in areas
identified by Afghanistan in addition we
feel that there is need to work together
with the United States as well as with
other regional countries to make
Afghanistan a hub a trade in transit hub
linking South and Central Asia with its
growing economy and expanding markets
India can and is willing to partner with
other countries and play the role of an
anchor for long term process
charity and stability in the region in
the broader regional context of the
ongoing changes in the asia-pacific
region there is today much greater
awareness between our two countries on
our Asian Pacific identities we are
witnessing the rise simultaneously of
several powers in the asia-pacific
region and new questions are being
raised about the role and
responsibilities of extra regional
powers the region is undergoing rapid
change and throwing up new challenges of
reconciling historical differences with
growing interdependence we have always
been conscious of our Asian identity of
our location at the strategic and
cultural crossroads of Asia the future
of the asia-pacific region is of vital
importance to India's own future the
u.s. to regards the region as one of
special strategic focus we are aware of
that the safety of the sea lanes of
communication in the Indian Ocean is
crucial for economic growth not just for
India and the u.s. but for the entire
region maritime trade routes in the
Indian Ocean are vital for international
commerce and global energy security and
we have a common interest in combating
threats such as piracy one-fifth of the
world's energy supplies now travel
across the Indian Ocean therefore we
have agreed India and the United States
to enhance our maritime security
cooperation for instance we are working
together with the US and the
international community to combat piracy
in the Gulf of Aden and off the coast of
Somalia when President Obama visited
India last November he and Prime
Minister Dr Manmohan Singh spelt out the
shared vision of both countries for
peace stability and prosperity in Asia
the Indian Ocean and Pacific regions we
have agreed to work together and with
other countries of the region for
evolution of an open balanced and
inclusive security and he can
Tomic architecture for the region we
believe that this would need to be a
consensus based process so that all
stakeholders can make their respective
contributions to regional security India
aspires to this vision in cooperation
with all countries including the US
through partnership consultation and
dialogue as the u.s. prepares to
participate in the East Asia Summit in
november this year we will continue our
consultations to ensure that the summit
has a productive outcome India and the
u.s. have been described as natural
strategic partners our relationship is
in a state of constant evolution in a
rapidly changing world we will move
forward and deepen our strategic
partnership guided by our long-term
objectives and shared ideals of
democratic functioning to meet the
important challenges of our times and to
advance peace and prosperity in an
increasingly interdependent and
interconnected world with that I'd be
happy to take a few questions thank
questions there are people with the
microphones if you raise your hand and
let's have pointed questions short so we
can have as many as we possibly can in
15 minutes or so yes and just see who
you want sure ambassador my name is just
meet the huge a the pleasure of working
with the former ambassador ambassador
before that well I was in Washington the
question was to do with the recent
assassination of Minister rabbani in
Afghanistan obviously India's had many
concerns with the reconciliation process
and I was wondering what role you see
India now having in that process and
what role you see your neighbor Pakistan
having well we did have the opportunity
to consult with Professor rabbani on a
number of occasions before this tragic
assassination happened we were in Kabul
a few months ago and one of our stops on
that to a worse to meet professor
rabbani and talk to him about the
process of reconciliation and how he
looked at it and how he was proceeding
with it and just two months ago just
before i handed over charges foreign
secretary he was in delhi with his team
with from the High Peace Council to talk
to us and he was very interested at that
time looking at how India as a
pluralistic society with a large Muslim
community was with managing this
diversity and how India has become known
around the world for its moderate
Islamic community by large the Muslims
of India live in peace with the other
communities and in fact the day Obon
school for instance in India
traditionally
has been a whole hallmarked for its
moderate voice but it somehow in the
rest of the region that's not the case I
mean it has muted and transmuted into
something else so I think professor
rabbani had embarked despite the fact
that he was a very complex figure and
had managed to survive the ups and downs
of Afghan politics over the last two
three decades he I think had genuine had
a genuine commitment to seeing how
reconciliation with Taliban factions and
with the diverse groups that were
fighting basically to promote intra
Afghan Drake reconciliation also our
attitude to that was that the red lines
on you know reconciliation with the
Taliban should not be lost sight of I
know that there's a debate on whether
that should have been an outcome or that
should be part of the process but but
India has all india had always been very
clear about the fact that there were
certain lines that should not be crossed
that they should give up violence that
they should subscribe to the Afghan
Constitution that they should observe
terrorism that they should respect the
rights of women so I think that was
understood also by the High Peace
Council of obviously in Afghanistan
today reconciliation seems to be a very
distant dream if you go by the sequence
of events and you see the horrible
violence that has been unleashed on
Afghanistan in fact that it's a
cascading effect of violence that you
see I think professor Rob on e's
assassination raises very fundamental
questions about where reconciliation is
headed and and I think you've seen the
statements coming from President Karzai
about the futility as he sees it and in
the sense of frustration it is which is
very natural you know for somebody to
have given what has happened President
Karzai is going to be visiting India
very shortly in the next couple of days
and we will have to see what the outcome
of his discussions in delhi will be
we've maintained close touch our prime
minister was in Kabul a few months ago
we're very concerned obviously about the
about the continuing terrorism in the
AfPak region and this has an effect on
us it has an effect on Afghanistan it
has an effect on all the other countries
in the region also I think apart from
strengthening Afghan capacity and the
ability to deal with their security
situation and the institutions of
governance and as I said intra Afghan
reconciliation I think they will have to
be some system of governance in the
country that will enable different
voices to come together but voices that
have given up violence and I think the
regional countries India Iran Russia
China Pakistan the Central Asian
Republics would all have to work
together to ensure that Afghanistan is
an independent sovereign country and
which is able to deal with its problems
on its own which is able to trade freely
with other countries I think basically
this whole system of transition in
Afghanistan is hugely hugely complicated
and complex but I think the existence of
safe havens and the and the operations
of groups I mean the word from the
Afghan government today has been that
there was cross-border involvement in
the rabbani assassination so we have to
get to the root of all this and I think
most importantly Pakistan will have to
turn the searchlight on itself in this
regard my name is each on Barney and I'm
our undergraduate student at here um the
question I had was with the recent
ongoing events in India with the
anti-corruption campaign the scans and
things like that how do you think this
is affecting the india-us a relationship
I think the india-us relationship is
strong it's durable it's it has very
stable foundations and I think
the fact that we discuss a whole
spectrum of issues in this partnership
speaks for the strength of this
relationship India's internal affairs
are internal to India I think the world
from outside sees the strength of our
openness and the transparent way in
which we deal with our problems nothing
is hidden from the rest of the world
what you see is what you get when it
comes to India and India has
self-correcting mechanisms to deal with
these problems and you have a government
you had democratic institutions you have
a parliament and you have a judiciary
that is that has stated very clearly
that they want to address these demands
that have been made by civil society and
by the anti-corruption movement and to
come up with viable solutions that
preserve the strength of our democratic
institutions and that do not detract or
diminish the value of Parliament or the
judiciary or the laws that we have put
in place to deal with these matters over
the years hum professor Mohammed Meah
vice-chancellor maulana azad national or
do university had rabadi since reference
of Abbas Afghanistan is made in
political sense him and then our
relations with the Afghanistan and I
were concerned with Afghanistan is very
well known you know and you talked about
the women empowerment of in relation to
Afghanistan what educational institution
in India what you visualize can do to
empower women in Afghanistan Eunice and
this is very important in the from the
point of view that we also talking and
doing lot of things to empower women in
our country months yes that's that's
very true I think where women of
Afghanistan are concerned we are already
doing when I spoke about the development
assistance that India is extending to
Afghanistan we've done a lot of work in
women's empowerment also and the
self-employed we
Association the savor of Emma debat has
been involved and we've created the
bodies on Anna in Kabul which is
basically for women's empowerment we
teach them you know self-help work and
many girls in Kabul and the downs of
Afghanistan now go to school we have
young Afghan women who come to India for
short term courses even in things like
journalism the other day I was
addressing a group of radio journalist
radio and television journalists from
Kabul and small at other towns in
Afghanistan who were on a two-week
training in India and many of them were
women and it was very encouraging to see
I think Afghan women have traditionally
been very independent and very
self-confident and unfortunately for
them you know the twists and turns of
Afghan politics and the Civil War inside
the country have have destroyed the
lives of so many women so we would we
would very much like to see more and
more Afghan women come to India we are
offering scholarships one of the areas
in which we are focusing a lot of effort
is in development related areas like
agriculture like hospitals like
providing doctors english language
teaching and the numbers of afghan
students who are coming even
self-financed afghan students i'm not
not talking of the scholarships their
families like to send their girls to
India for higher studies so I think our
universities should really welcome these
students and provide them with that kind
of environment where they will feel at
home and where they can be well
integrated into the system that our
universities provide I think Hyderabad
is uniquely placed for that in fact
Indians is it is a country where Afghan
communities have come to over the
centuries almost every mid-sized town
and of course big cities and India have
of GaN communities who've been there for
generations so that's why we have about
500 people landing in Delhi Airport
every day from Afghanistan
because we have so many flights coming
not only from Cabo we have from Kandahar
for instance people coming for business
people coming for medical reasons people
coming to put their kids in school so so
this is a you know a bridge between the
two countries that is very strong and
there's a great deal of affection that
Indians feel for Afghans and Afghans
feel for Indians
thank you very much ambassador I'm
Maxwell kirschner lenhoff i'm a senior
chemistry major at yale and i was just
wondering um i know that with the
possible iranian proliferation of
nuclear weapons recently the United
States and Obama has spoken out about
taking sanctions versus Iran and India
being so close to Iran just you know in
terms of geographical terms I was just
wondering what you saw India's role as
you know stopping Iran from developing
nuclear weapons or how you saw India
fitting into this well let me say that
India has taken a very responsible and
very clearly enunciated position on the
issue of Iran's nuclear program Iran is
a member of the nuclear
non-proliferation treaty and it has
certain rights that it's entitled to for
development of peaceful uses of nuclear
energy under that dispensation but as
far as any intent or any move to develop
a nuclear weapons program is concerned
India has spoken out very clearly that
we are not for Iran's movement in that
direction and a couple of our voting
patterns in the IAEA have shown that I
mean we have not been supportive of
Iran's moves or inclinations in that
direction apart from that in Iran in
India we have a very close and
continuing dialogue on security
strategic foreign policy related issues
apart from trade and economic issues and
cultural matters Iran has a big presence
in Indian you know that there are 35
million Shia Muslims in India who are
part of the large Muslim community that
we have in our country and they have had
traditional linkages with Iran so Iran
is a country that is in that sense very
close to us culturally we have had
enormous interaction with Iran I was in
Iran two months ago and I visited Shiraz
and his fahan and everywhere I went I
could sense you know the the muffled
footsteps of history as it were that
link India and Iran together trade Iran
as far as energy security is concerned
is also very
important for us we twelve percent of
our import of crude petroleum comes from
Iran and in recent months because of the
sanctions imposed by the United States
and other European countries apart from
the UN sanctions there have been
difficulties in in effecting payments
for these imports from iran so to sum up
we cannot be entirely divorced from what
happens in Iran today and we have very
close and continuing linkages with Iran
but we've acted with a sense of
responsibility when it comes to Iran's
nuclear program my name is Arjun
Canadian I'm a second year MBA student
at the Yale School of Management one of
the discussions that we constantly have
is with respect to investments in india
and when it comes to venture investing
in specific in india now in the united
states most of venture investing
typically started with dual purpose
investments but unfortunately all sorts
of investment that's been happening in
india and continues to happen is in the
growth sector and there's very little
investing that's happening in the
venture sector now could you speak a
little bit the collaboration that has
been happening between the United States
and the end India when it comes to the
whole science and technology sector and
innovation such well that's the emphasis
I sought to give in my in my speech
today and I think the linkages between
research and R&D institutions so let's
say universities with industry which you
have in this country is not so well
established in India and I think that is
one area where when you talk of
educational collaboration and bringing
in business and industry to be a
partners in this we have a lot to learn
from the United States I mentioned the
health sector is one area where we can
have much more capital coming in and
know how technology innovation for co
development & Co research & Co
innovation between India and the United
States and finally agriculture we talk
of an evergreen revolution to to
supplant the green revolution of the 60s
in India
how do you increase agricultural
productivity how do you deal with
groundwater availability how do you
increase basically productivity and
productivity of crops that can provide
better nutrition to the vast numbers of
people who still live in poverty in
India so education health science and
technology agriculture all these are
areas where I believe we should be
having much more inputs from the United
States I think for political reasons and
for certain degrees of estrangement that
existed in the past for whatever reasons
this had not been happening but the
United States after President Obama's
visit last year announced that it would
be relaxing export controls on high
technology with India and that has begun
to happen with the removal of three of
our major entities from the entities
list and the announcement of removal of
certain export controls in crime control
elements in regional stability related
elements and exports from the United
States to India so we've made a
beginning in these areas and we intend
to build on it there is a bilateral
investment treaty in the works also
which should open up the universe a
little more thank you very much your
excellency yes two days back there was a
column in The Guardian which claimed
that that Indian government was denying
visas and deporting foreign
correspondents trying to cover Kashmir
chattisgarh another so sensitive areas
for instance david bursa me off USA how
do you respond to this column Creole to
identify yourself sorry I'm aniket I'm a
PhD student here Anna Kate from where
from Nasik India from Nasik Maharashtra
okay so I think in the particular case
you were referring to there was a
certain infringement of the rules the
person
concerned it come in on a tourist visa
in the past and reported on and used it
for journalistic purposes which is not
permitted under the rules and every
country you'll appreciate has certain
rules when it comes to giving visas to
foreigners I don't think we have stopped
journalists from coming in and reporting
on whether it's Kashmir or Chattisgarh
or whether it's the Maoist problems that
we have as i said to in answer to
another question our life in india is an
open book i don't think there is any
restriction on people coming in and
people speaking out you've seen the
nature of debate the tenor of debate in
India there are the hundred schools of
thought contending at this moment my
name is Samir kwatra I must rent at the
Forestry and environmental school for us
at the environmental school it is
heartening to see that energy and
climate change are one of the key
strategic areas of partnership between
the u.s. and India my question is that
when it comes to climate change
negotiations though the US and India
still continue to hold diametrically
opposing positions with the US
repeatedly refusing to ratify any
international treaty which does not have
emerging economies like India and China
so with key environments will summits
coming up in Durban and then in Rio do
you foresee any kind of a change in this
position and the two countries coming to
any kind of an agreement on climate
change I think that yes there are
obviously there are divergences of
position when it comes to the
multilateral negotiations on climate
change we bring in the developing
country dimension the United States and
the other your and its European partners
and Japan bring in the developed country
dimension so there is obviously going to
be a divergence but that doesn't stop
India and the United States from
cooperating in the field of energy and
the environment and especially in energy
efficiency in renewable energy
in clean energy this has become
enormously important we have an energy
dialogue which is very productive
between the two countries and we are
looking at as I said energy efficiency
especially in building projects in clean
energy in exploring things like shale
gas reserves in India so the canvas of
cooperation bilaterally between India
and the United States in the field of
environment is very productive is very
beneficial to both countries so I think
we are able to balance these two aspects
and being friends doesn't mean you have
to agree on everything friendship you
know should incorporate within itself
the power to say no sometimes Thank You
ambassador all my name is ashish mehta
i'm a political science student here at
yale my question has to do with the
palestinian quest for statehood at the
UN how do you view India's position in
this regard and what impact you think it
will have on the future of indo-us
relations considering the USA's position
how do i view India's position in this
regard I think it's absolutely correct
and unimpeachable I you know our support
for an independent variable Palestine a
Palestinian state that exists in peace
with Israel has been well stated and
articulated over the years and our
friends and partners know it the
Americans know it and when mrs. Clinton
septra Clinton met Minister Krishna just
last week in New York this matter was
discussed and the United States
understands where India comes from on
this and we have up we have our very
principled approach on this issue we
have long-standing ties with the
Palestinian people the people of India
you know every democracy has its
constituency's and in India our
constituency is the Indian people and
the Indian people support for the
Palestinian peer cause and the you know
the problems that the Palestinian people
face have been very well stated and they
are very well entrenched in the
psychology of the Indian people so that
is not
something we can just purchase jettison
or change so in the Security Council we
have you know stated that position very
clearly and we've made it very clear
that we do support the aspirations of
the Palestinian people for that
independent viable state but it should
of course exist in peace with Israel and
matters of this nature need to be solved
not through violence but through
dialogue mmm I'm a JK i'm from school of
planning in architecture bhopal i want
to ask that there was fun announcement
that there would be indo-us higher
education council would be established
for new institutions in india as you
know IITs and it's-- nsps etcetera have
been expanded for new institutions in
india will that council would have some
role indo-us higher education are
canceled well let's see for how the
summit proceeds we are just on the eve
of having the higher education summit
we'll have to see what the outcomes are
but the desire is to intensify
cooperation that will benefit higher
education institutions in india of the
sort that you mentioned to infuse more
you know know-how and experience that
comes from outside universities just
today when i was talking to the Yale
faculty earlier this evening the idea
that came to mind for instance is why
don't we have why can't we consider the
possibility of more tripartite or
trilateral consultations between India
China and the United States on these
issues because the Chinese have had a
long-standing collaboration with the
Americans from the days you know when
you look back at the founding of peking
university or the founding of ching hua
university or the founding of fudan
university you had American Americans
who came to establish those University
so there's been a very close linkage so
now that we are thinking of expanding
our linkages with the Americans in these
fields i think these three countries can
really build a future that will
be good for the for the university going
population in in all the three countries
another year student of the last
question yield student thank you first
we would like to thank you for coming
here and spending some good time with us
i'm at yale school of management
leadership and healthcare program and my
question to use their recent changes in
the health care policy going on apoorva
patel there are some recent changes
going on in healthcare policy within us
with the burgeoning cost and their
significant deficiencies in india and
healthcare market so could you please
elaborate little bit on how is there
some expedited initiative taken by
indian government to bring in healthcare
investment back in india and like some
other strategic value propositions that
you have for us I must be honest I'm not
an expert in that field so I won't be
able to answer that question with that
level of expertise that you perhaps
would want from from you know health
care expert but I spoke about
collaboration in development of drugs of
medicines we've set a set up a global
disease detection center now through a
bilateral mou between India and the
United States so we have started
consultations on how the two countries
can cooperate and do co-innovation as i
said in co development in dealing with
chronic disease detection treatment
development of new vaccines generic
drugs i spoke about in how US companies
and indian companies are doing excellent
work in this field so we need to
institutionalize this a little better we
need to see how we can provide more
funding there's not much funding that
comes from the United States for these
things at the moment and that perhaps is
understandable given the problems that
the economy faces here at this moment
but ideally we should be doing much more
in the public sector than even even in
the private sector the Green Revolution
in India happened because of the
fact that the US government agencies
were intimately involved in providing
that that those inputs that X those
expertise that expertise that we needed
at that point of time so if we can
recreate that to some extent and build
that balance between public and private
and public private partnerships it will
help thank you thank you thank you very
much ambassador all for coming here on a
weekend and I think that the interest
India is indicated by the fact that you
have a full house on sunday evening
which is not the easiest thing to do
with you thank you very much indeed